hello I'm in the south guy remember so
you don't have to well if you've ever
been to the Magic Kingdom chances are
one of your favorite rides is the
Haunted Mansion now could it not be with
its endless creativity gothic atmosphere
and so many clever visuals that no one
could see it in one view the Haunted
Mansion has become one of the theme
parks most praised attractions so when
Disney had a surprise monster hit with
their Pirates of the Caribbean movie
they figured maybe bring in the same
amount of cinematic effort to one of the
most famous rides of all time might be
called for here as well best way to
begin well let's have any Murphy star in
it
how could one of Disney's most playfully
dark and gothic ideas be given to such
an obviously wrong actor not that a
Murphy can't do good work he just does
it so rarely this is like putting Will
Ferrell in Batman or Sarah Silverman and
Sophie's Choice or Pierce Brosnan in a
music oh yeah we're still paying for it
but some actors obviously don't go with
some and the sad thing is they try to
tailor what could have been a really
awesome ideal with the dark sense of
humor to a story is intriguing is the
ones you find on the site of Happy Meal
boxes hell even happy new boxes are
looking creepier than anything in this
film so does anything after the original
creativity of the ride well let's take a
look with Eddie Murphy's haunted mansion
so boy who literally has nothing to do
with anything shows up just in the house
can tell him to piss off well you heard
the movie it's a go away it wants to get
rid of us as much as the writing does we
then transition via shit-eating grin to
Eddie Murphy trying to sell a house to
over actor number one and over actor
number two it's just what we've been
looking for
there aren't enough plugs yo yo every
house we look at you find something to
pick at oh I just know what I like would
you like a divorce Oh
cuz I'll bring it oh god hey huh if I
had a nickel for how many divorces were
caused by plugs actually that sounds
worse than I meant it to be we love the
house he closes up another deal at the
Rikki tikki room where the happy couple
wants to celebrate but Murphy has to get
to his anniversary dinner in time for oh
it's this bullshit setup see I don't
know if they're gonna do the clumsy
dreamer who has to prove himself the
cowardly weirdo who has to prove himself
but now I see it's the workaholic
douchebag who has to prove himself
because as we all know with family films
there's only three stories to tell and
see how the last film combining a black
father with goes use this method to set
fuckin greatness it only makes sense to
use it again here what a world of maybe
a child-size handful of possibilities
did you just sell their house I sure did
because we're looking to buy and seeing
how Murphy clearly for some reason
doesn't believe in business cards he
misses the dinner with his very angry
wife okay we'll tell you what we gonna
do we gonna take off this weekend what
like we did last year with the kids just
us and the kids for the whole weekend
how's that Sam
how about Orlando I bought so many
annoying characters for their attraction
surely we can get in for free she greets
to the trip a travel-size Chris rockier
is afraid of a spider in his room and
it's time I teach you how to kill a
spider the right way all right
yeah I remember how many kids had
Houdini posters hanging in their room
maybe there was a plot throw those going
to go somewhere but again they probably
saw how well worked and ghost dad and
seriously movie nobody should have this
many strange connections to that fucking
film though eyes yeah yeah right but
they get a call to look at a house that
could be a big payday from Murphy and
decides to take a look with his family
before their weekend break Megan don't
slam the door like that it's very
sensitive
it's a car dad ah it's not just a car a
very delicate piece of machinery
Shh you mean what you just said should
you well can't imagine why that scene
with put in there you see a less obvious
setup with bowling pins having the words
break me written on him so they enter
the haunted mansion well not badly
design does look like every other creepy
movie house you've seen before nothing
really sets it that much apart Hey look
there goes Casper Morticia Count Olaf
and Owen Wilson reminding us to be
scared really creepy that's were
introduced to the butler of the house
and clearly the only person having any
fun in this film Terence Stamp that's
right
General Zod is playing this part and if
you want an idea for what you're in for
take a listen to how he says his very
first line of OHS and I'm not even
kidding that is literally how he says
every single line in this film he has a
machine-gun vibrato that will make Elmer
Fudd's laugh jealous the mustard sounds
wonderful storm has flooded the road I'm
hunting wabbits Oh seriously sod what
are you doing in this film well remember
I said I did some movies in the past I
wasn't very proud of No
well yeah but I thought you meant what
thought I meant what I just kind of made
the assumption that you you thought I
was doing porn didn't you it's just the
way you're dressed you know I just don't
know I see just because a man wears all
leather and exposes his man cleavage
means he must be some sort of gentleman
or not it's just most people outside of
that industry don't usually dress that
well according to the matrix although
stone Ian's dress this way it doesn't
mean I have sex for a mother okay okay
I'm sorry I made that assumption case
I'd ready when you are
drop the pants and let's get filming
well I'm doing it now that's only
because certain opportunities have
opened up for me opportunity yes
apparently when the Man of Steel lasers
your balls off everybody wants to see
what it looks like might as well make a
little chit Ching off of it I'm gonna
forget anything about your genitalia
with Zed and get back to the review fine
I got work to do too I guess I should
get used to that Sosa takes them to the
owner of the house named Edward Gracy
tell me mr. Ellison do you believe in
ghosts where hair brought my career back
from the dead several times does that
count
okay I know the voice you're going for
but has anyone ever actually heard
another person talk like that you're
making Michael Crawford sound like the
micro machine guy afraid there will be
no leaving the mansion tonight okay it's
a star cuz the viewers like of the
knowledge Christine so they can't leave
the mansion and decide to spend the
night there will there be anything else
that you require sir are you gonna get
some chocolate
pardon you know the little chocolates
they put on the hotel pillow some tap
dance topics on the pillow
save it for Shrek 12 no of course no one
actually sleeps and they start snooping
around the house because well it's a big
creepy place and they all have penny
gadget syndrome
interest ravit discovers the batpoles
while the daughter also makes a shocking
discovery what do you think it is or at
least it would be shocking if she was
even the tiniest bit surprised by it I
think it wants us to follow it it does
wants us to follow it dude where the
iPhone generation the only time were
ever actually shocked is when Facebook
changes their layout they did it again
my life is over
the wife as well bumps into Gracie who
seems to be quite taken with her so much
so these where he only has one setting
in this film
whimsical grand parties dancing laughter
I really must show you there's nothing
to be afraid of it's cooked and above
all hope even what he's saying really
sad stuff he seems bizarrely inspired by
it these walls are filled with so many
memories
some of them painful you can tell by the
smile on my face I'm so upset
elizabeth is the story that haunts these
walls you see a long time ago she oh I
guess we're not doing that that odd
transition the kids follow the flame II
Smurf testicle deeper into the house
where they come across a picture of a
woman that of course looks just like
their mom what are you doing hearing
you're not supposed to be up here this
is unspeakable
unspeakable inconceivable even come on
high five you knew that was coming come
on give me a high five and you put your
hand on the computer screen and give me
a high five come on high five high five
me bro high five if you actually do it I
will be concerned about you
azad enters the room and they tell them
to hide children
no children my children the children she
wasn't supposed to bring along with that
brainless husband of hers those rascally
rapscallions really oh my riches if I
had to listen to another word from that
insufferable fool I think I would have
best of course sir what a fool I'll be
the only one tasting the scenery thank
you the final arrangements have been
made nothing further will interfere with
the master's plan now if you'll excuse
me my monster from his lab began to rise
meanwhile Murphy stumbles across another
big surprise terrible CG that could have
easily been done with makeup
hey dream works at the only company that
gets to turn me into a
computer-generated jackass he then comes
across Madame Leota who if you remember
from the ride was played by the same
actress who played Maleficent and
Cinderella's stepmother so obviously if
they had to get somebody just as
dignified to play though you fucking
kidding me
there is great evil in this house a
Devils curse it seeks to destroy you
okay look I have nothing against
Jennifer Tilly she's funny she's
talented and surprisingly random a god
is a poker but this is meant for a
dignified voice every time I hear her I
keep expecting her to get legal advice
from Jim Carrey Emily
she then lifts him up into the air with
a bunch of instruments because really no
reason except it was on the right I'm
trying to out chuckle Chris Tucker
you
coming to the big screen Walt Disney
Pictures proudly presents gargoyles from
the studio that put Eddie Murphy in the
haunted mansion Keira Knightley as a
pirate and Mila Kunis as the Wicked
Witch we present another phenomenal miss
casting with Kanye West as Goliath yeah
I'm stoned by day and batshit crazy
monster by night also I'm apparently in
a movie because you love our film
versions of Cinderella and Beauty and
the Beast even though we already have
film versions of Cinderella and Beauty
and the Beast why do that shit we bring
you another misunderstanding of source
material by caste Ellen DeGeneres as
ELISA Massa bitch who the fuck are you
think I'm your love interest say what
you clam chowder cracker
don't worry I seen worse I dated Anne
Heche that's an old joke kids if you
don't get it ask your parents of course
if you're watching this you are your
parents okay not so fast with Kevin
Costner as the villainous
Santa totes I am Zenit oh Santa I don't
care I have sent on my robotic army if
you wish to save the people you will
have to fly up there and stop them bitch
that fuck I won't do any fine let's have
a crown of thorns or halo what he
supposed to do let all those people die
maybe shed it post man I could buy you
like my white AIIMS a next oh dammit oh
I don't care I didn't watch the show
wings he writes letters over fessor
action yes they should be in his left
exhale toes and it should really help
gargoyles coming soon to a theater near
hey let go of me I'm gonna let you
finish but I want you to know that
bonkers is one of the greatest shows of
all time and we deserve a movie about a
cartoon character and a cock we have to
we need 3 hey you want to hear about the
show I'm producing that's gonna bomb
bitch don't make me chop you up and
smoke you I am Santa hos
so Gracie continues to tell Murphy's
wife about his dead wife blaming the
events happened to his grandfather
instead of to himself and he loved her
more than life itself
but they were from different worlds
and couldn't be together hey hey we
tiptoe towards racism not existing in
princess in the frog we can do the same
thing here yeah so the kids meet up with
Murphy and try to find out what to do
for the truth to be known you must find
the key are you talking about ball lady
what key enter the tomb under the great
dead oak and travel down deep under the
ground and there you will find the key
that must be found okay where is this
clause that says that side characters
must speak in bullshit riddles and
rhymes why can't they just say don't
fucking here and do fucking that because
fucking this a fun scavenger hunt is one
thing but when lives are on the line
skip the frank gorshin cock tease the
servants help them in their quest and
suddenly turn blue because pac-man eat
the corner pellet I don't know and they
come across more boots recreating the
ride dead yes I see dead people hey that
doesn't date this at all what you just
throw in a getting jiggy reference while
you're at it he wants to try to get
jiggy with my wife pretty much why the
hell not I also forget to mention that
you are the weakest link houston we have
a problem and somebody just did a great
cave drawing of a buffalo this was to
have been her wedding dress
it would have been lovely as still if
she'd ever had a chance to wear it uh
that's nice mr. Gracie but we've been
talking about this for three hours now
can we finally change the subject heels
will install everything away from love
well now he's broke dead end cursed
nice move right I stepped in a 40's
cartoon sound effect dilute dilute
Abdullah cryptos Creek in the tomb sells
Quaker and has his typical bad
adaptations they take one of the coolest
parts of the original source and make it
easily the most annoying part of the
entire movie it's
item by the love the silvery I'm gonna
help my wife
she'll be coming round about when she
comes she go she'll be coming are you
laughing yet no fucking more Vicky
where's the beautiful key your key oh
your two-year-old is laughing but you're
not unless you're smoking a gigantic
brick of pawpaw we're annoying and
obnoxious and you probably should have
shot us please don't hold back then and
give us what you go it's a warning how
do you know that I study Latin for three
years dad you thought it was done
remember gee a daughter who speaks Latin
and a son with a Houdini poster stop the
realistic kid measurements are off the
chart
the son stays behind as the daughter
goes with him down below the shield it's
the second marker but it's guarded by
the walking doll causing them to drop
the key let's get the key
at everything completely under control
and I'm not just saying that because
every person who has ever said that in
the history of mankind has always met
with the exact opposite reaction oh my
god
creepy creatures are actually in front
of me and not CG this is so rare in this
movie come on can you see G in kazoo or
the Twilight baby or something ah there
you go fake CG spiders cut film film
naked for a second sorry I need the
customary minute and a half to perform
the overcoming my fears clash a minute
22 minute 23 oh I want to send this
movie so they seem to have the key or do
they oh yeah I got oh I guess they do
that was needed and Murphy discovers
that Zod is the one who killed Gracie's
wife years ago so he throws Murphy out
of the house and locks up the kids in
the trunk you might be wondering where
the hell is the mother in all this well
naturally did she still listening to
Gracie story this whole time Christ lady
it'd give more time to this guy than
Peter Jackson does to The Hobbit
do you believe that love is about second
chances yes don't you recognize me at
all
mr. Gracie I thought certainly bringing
you back to Gracie Manor would help you
so he tells her that she's the spirit of
his lost love but she has no memory
whatsoever a copy huh is her sir
the gypsy woman prophesy had her return
but she doesn't remember in time she
will sir I assure you she will shoe
remember after I beat it into her I'm
not Elizabeth we wouldn't want anything
to happen to the children now would we
so he tells her that unless she marries
Gracie to lift the curse he'll
I don't know send her kids through
baggage claim and she begrudgingly
agrees but Gracie is confused by her
crying while walking down the aisle
tears of joy
but you can trust your creepy dark eyed
whispering voice too darling
whew but the dignified Madame Leota
rolls in like a hamster ball and gives
Murphy the motivation not to give up I'm
finally gonna follow through am i loving
the car Jo only to have no reactions
that's not following from the loving the
car Jo gutterball really beloved jaar
jaar gathered together here in the sight
of God it's howling dog and accent we
all gathered here today here to
celebrate these true soul Murphy hurries
to save the kids
fucking McCoys asshole so he defeats the
night yeah I believe it too and gets the
kids out of the trunk to help him save
his wife yeah I got a few objections
Elizabeth didn't kill herself he did
he's been lying to you all along that is
absurd whoo - yelps heard it makes me
want to laugh oh gods demon army has
come to burn our heroes up
are they confusingly decide to take him
instead because he said the D word so
the spirits of do you really give a shit
come in for do you really need a reason
it takes out of the way because would
you even listen if I told you God what
kind of world is this where Terence
Stamp goes to hell but Eddie Murphy is
untouched but it seems the poison has
taken its effect on his wife leading to
Murphy's most genuinely authentic
phoned-in performance he is yet given
Sara Sara come on please Sara Sara I
love you Sara please I love you so much
come on honey we had dinner reservations
I love God and those are so mildly
annoying to cancel but the radioactive
knobby turret arrives again possessing
her with the spirit of Elizabeth who
brings Murphy's wife back to life
thought I lost you too I'm back sir I'm
back at least until Pluto - there's a
long uphill climb from there
thus the curse is lifted and all the
spirits are freed at last what are you
talking about we're going to heaven you
can't take it with you I can't don't you
know you never mess with a Sicilian when
death is on the line the tale is well
ended for those who have passed now that
I agree with the only people who leave
this film happy are those who are dead
mom Leona oh shut up are we there yet so
I guess not all the souls were taken the
really annoying ones were left behind
and for some reason the family decided
to keep them because wouldn't you also
want to take them home it'd be like
having a hearing aid that's also a fire
alarm nothing but pleasant sounds all
year round which is definitely not what
was in this film what should have been a
film on par with the creativity in front
of Pirates of the Caribbean instead
turns out to be a series of performances
effects and story threads all set on
autopilot yeah everything feels half-ass
with no passion put into it and it's
really a shame there's a lot of
possibilities with the Haunted Mansion
hell a lot of the characters on the ride
already seemed a hat story set up so why
make up this one with Eddie Murphy as
the focus with all the reboots that
Disney is doing recently this is one
that desperately needs I mean come on
don't you see this as like an animated
film with the same people who did frozen
a wreck-it ralph work on the story and
the look it'd be amazing this is still
an incredible opportunity waiting to
happen but until then if ever this is
all we have a wasted opportunity of
creativity and imagination leaving
little to no impression whatsoever ain't
no fucking way I'm hitchhiking a ride on
this wagon anytime soon but on the plus
side I think I've perfected my whispery
voice Butler so over
you're gonna crack remember son you
don't have to
you
that is absurd